zetes pingouins se charger on l'a pris
aux russes
mais c'est un trophée
nous sommes ailleurs pin les faubourgs
de kiev ici le foncier virus a été
repoussée pour beaucoup la guerre est
terminée mais pas pour arte m
tu vois ici la mère de mon meilleur ami
a été tué
quand ce niçois hybride et kaka on a
retrouvé une
partie de son corps
ce quartier du champ trop dire pile a
été le théâtre très violents combats fin
mars
mais revenir dans ce genre d'endroit ça
nous renvoie des images
j'entends les bois de tous ces gens qui
meurent
[Musique]
et moi que j'allais mal et je n'ai rien
pu faire pour eux
heureusement
pierre pin le bilan des victimes civiles
s'élèvent à plusieurs centaines parmi
les rescapés ils sont quelques-uns à
avoir décidé de revenir
je veux continuer de vivre ici je vais
trouver un moyen chercher un nouveau
boulot pour l'instant on essaie de
réparer
au début de la guerre artem à évacuer
anna sa femme et son fils david rossi
vient de revenir à l'hermine
il a changé
il est devenu plus dur
il est toujours sur le qui-vive
concentré mais en même temps je dirais
qu'il est devenu sentimentale je sais
qu'à cause de ce qu'il a vécu il y a
beaucoup d'émotions contradictoires en
lui
malheureusement quand on dit la vie doit
reprendre comme avant
je sais aussi au fond de moi que c'est
impossible
est ce que vous êtes inquiet pour votre
fils penser que tout ça c'est terminé
non ce n'est pas fini
ce sera terminé quand toutes nos villes
seront reprises
quand il n'y aura plus un centimètre de
notre territoire volés par les russes